he looked every bit the cool confident
champion but it soon became clear this
was not Antony Joshua at his focused
fest it was a fight he was expected to
breathe with a twenty five to one
favorite faulted in the third round
before anteriors jr. delivered one of
boxing's greatest upsets falling twice
in the seventh round Joshua experienced
his first professional defeat and the
loss of all three of his IBF WBO and WBA
heavyweight titles for the relatively
unknown mexican-american it was a
triumph hard for and I can't believe I
just made my dreams come true
commentators speculated Joshua had lost
focus or become complacent acclaim he
denied as a fire as I said I don't
overlook anyone I see you Toby look
someone because of their shape or their
record or whatnot but these guys are
coming to win and he's a better man
tonight he done his job for years he's
been the sports golden boy an Olympic
champion as an amateur followed by a
seamless transition to the professional
game many hoped he could beat the first
heavyweight fighter for over a decade to
hold all the major world titles but fans
may take heart from boxing upsets of the
past Lennox Lewis went on to win world
titles following a shock defeat to
Hassan Rahman in 2001 and Mike Tyson
also came back from an underdog upset
against Buster Douglas I think he's got
it within him but the whole points about
sport the whole point about boxing is
that he has to go out and demonstrate
that when he gets to rematch with Andy
Ruiz if that rematch can be made is
contractually in place they look they're
looking to enact it next but of course
everything has got to come together for
that to happen
Joshua's vowed to get the belts back
that rematch is likely to come before
the end of the year but his fans will
hope this is a hiccup not a halting on
his way to boxing superstardom Helen Ann
Smith skinnies